>> SACHS: Okay, thanks for coming and not
running off to get in line for your new toy.
My name is Eric Sachs. I'm a product manager
at Google. Currently I'm a product manager
for two different teams, the Google Security
team as well as I'm actually the product manager
counterpart for Google's CIO, which is an
interesting pair of responsibilities, but
we're actually doing a lot of work in the
security area to offer our CIO, sort of our
internal enterprise teams some new options
to use cloud computing. I'm going to spend
some time talking about that today. I have
actually been at Google now almost six years
and, prior to that, about ten years in the
corporate e-mail host environment, so, I've
been on both the enterprise and the consumer
side for a long time. And what we're going
to focus on today is sort of the mish-mash
of different standards in the security space,
especially the ones that are used in more
of our cloud computing web services environment.
And, in particular, I'm not trying to make
all of you security experts. What I see as
my goal as a product manager is to make people
aware of, you know, new solutions to problems
in the past that just seemed unsolvable. And
so, you know, I get this from a lot of people
who would, you know, talk about themselves
as being security experts that handle security
expert in, you know, area one and two, but,
you know, trying to keep all the rest, you
know, I just can't. And, in particular, you
know, I wouldn't even suggest trying. You
know, learn the areas that you care about
and then, you know, keep an eye on those.
No one can keep track of all of this stuff.
And, in particular, one of the themes we're
going to talk about today is that a lot of
technology has been developed in the consumer
space the last few years for security purposes
and is actually being really heavily adopted
on the enterprise side. And, in fact, the
consumer can produce who, you know, created
some of this stuff. They weren't pushing for
the use of it in enterprises. The enterprises
grabbed it and have run with it. To be honest,
we're catching up as much as anything else.
So, I'm going to go through two primary sections
today in my presentation and then at the end--apparently,
now we should have a good 20 minutes for Q&A,
so, we've got mic set up at the end for people
who want to ask questions. And we are videoing
this, so, we're going to try to ask people
to come up to the mic when do they have questions.
Two sections that I'm going to go in today,
the first, Federated Login, something, probably
a lot of you are familiar with. However, historically,
this has been more about large enterprise
type of thing. What I want to talk to the
audience today about is, you know, what if
you're a small or a medium size business or
what if you're a software-as-a-service vendor.
There's a lot of interesting evolution in
this space that is worth knowing about. And
then about two-thirds of the session today,
I'm going to be talking about web service
authentication. I don't mean a web service
authenticating an end-user, you know, logging
in. What I mean is web service A making a
call to web service B, say, to make a request
to change someone's salary. And we're going
to talk about how the receiving web bot application
identifies the calling web application and
a whole bunch of scenarios where this gets
interesting. So, let me jump into this first
part, sort of this federated login. So, many
of you have probably, you know, experienced
this yourself working either at a large enterprise
where they've deployed a single sign-on system
across a bunch of corporate applications or
maybe you experienced this as a corporate
user of, say, Google or Yahoo where you logged
in once and all of a sudden, you logged in
to a bunch of services from those providers
without being logged in. So, traditionally,
this has been more of a gain for large enterprises,
large consumer websites. And most of them
purchased packaged software products, you
know, for this. And the standard in this space
pretty well evolves really solid. However,
if you're going to run this, you know, you
have to be prepared to make sure that this
system is up and running all the time. So,
you know, we're talking about service in multiple
data-centers, multiple, you know, servers
even in the same data-centers to keep it up
and running. And things start to get a little
bit more complicated especially in the large
enterprise scenario if you then want to enable
some of your employees to log in to some software-as-a-service
applications, Salesforce, Google Apps being
examples, and you want your employees to log
in to them without having to enter their password
again. So, that's sort of the traditional
example. But let's talk about some of the
stuff that's happened the last year or so,
which is that a lot of small and medium businesses
said, "This sounds great. I'm going to go
buy one these single sign-on software packages.
I'm going to deploy it on my Windows active
directory server sitting on the desk over
there." And they've got sort of a term for
this. SSO was sort of the abbreviation of
Single Sign-On. Well, within small and medium
businesses, they'd like to make a joke out
of it. Now, it's a Single Source Of failure.
And what they mean by that is a lot of companies
have the experience of they deployed one of
these systems sitting under someone's desk,
10 o'clock at night, that server dies and
their CEO is in India and is trying to log
in to one of the applications like their e-mail
system. And even though the e-mail system
is up and running, their login system is down.
So, you know, if you're a small-medium business
running this, you know, on a single server
in a single office applying a single internet
connection, don't do it. It's not worth the
pain they're going to cause. So, seeing this,
a number of vendors in this space, Ping, simplified
some others, realized, wait, here's an opportunity.
Instead of providing this as software to these
smaller companies, let's provide a service
to them. Just as companies can outsource their
e-mail or their calendars or their 41K, now
they can outsource running one these identity
provider services. Like I say, you can do
this today with a couple of companies like
Ping supplied and then a lot of the e-mail
hosting providers, Microsoft, Lotus, Google,
Yahoo, et cetera are working on clarifying
the standard so that we can offer this same
functionality as well, and, so, you know,
the goal is that, you know, that CEO traveling
in India, you know, if he wants to log in
to any application, when it's a highly reliable
web service that is taking his password, figuring
out who he is and then handling the job of
getting him logged in to the different application
he wants to hit. So let me give an example
of how this might work. So, this example of
a company called Appirio was really heavily
focused on using cloud computing, software-as-a-service
offering. They tried to have really minimal
desktop, laptops for their employees and use
services like Google Apps for mail and calendar
or Salesforce for their CRM application. And,
you know, what they would have liked to have
done in the past is they would like for their
employees to log in on one webpage and then
be able to go to Salesforce or Google or Plaxo
or some other enterprise app and just be signed
in again magically speaking. However, they
haven't been able to do this historically.
Well, one of the things that we've been working
on with PingConnect and the OpenId's standards
community is a way of actually making this
work. So, Ping is a company who had sort of--the
red box on the right--they're really experts
at a lot of this federated login technology.
And they've realized how to make stuff talk
to us in Salesforce using a whole bunch of
protocols, other SaaS vendors, business to
business partners, even sort of--down in the
bottom, left-hand corner--hooking back into
applications you might run on premise. They're
good at that, but, you know, still somebody
has to be responsible for asking the user
for their password. So, in this case, what
we did is we said, "You know what? Tom at
Appirio, he's already used to going and logging
in to his mail service operated by Google.
So, Google knows how to authenticate him."
So we used OpenId--which is another federated
login technology as sort of a glue between
Google and Ping, and we said, you know, "Hey,
let's have Tom go and log in to his mail.
He's all set." Now, if Tom goes and types
salesforce.appirio.com in his browser, he's
going to be redirected to Salesforce with
a request to access Appirio's information.
Salesforce will say, "Oh, okay well, that
domain's logins are handed by PingConnect."
They'll route from there. PingConnect will
say, "Oh, okay, well, now I need to check
who from Appirio is logged in," bounces the
user back to Google, and Google says, "Okay,
well, it's Tom," you know, tells PingConnect,
"It's Tom," and PingConnect knows how to,
you know, talk to a variant of federated login
that Salesforce uses and tells them that Tom's
logged in. And the same thing applies to a
bunch of others. They think it could make
this work like I say to these business to
business partners, to these enterprise apps,
et cetera. And so we actually have this live
and running with them now, you know, and,
hopefully, once we finalized some of the OpenId
community standards, it makes this more generally
available. Some of the--one of the other things
to note is there's another purple box in the
middle labeled "Plaxo," which points out that
as these standards do coalesce and really
become not, you know, standards with some
variance but some standard with very little
variance. It's even possible that some of
these e-mail hosting providers, whether it's
a Google, a Yahoo or Microsoft, any of us
can act as a federated login provider, you
know, directly to an application. So, Plaxo
is one who, for example, already does this
with Google today for our Gmail users. So,
you know, Tom, all of these stuff is invisible
to him. He enters his password once, goes
to any web app he needs from the enterprise,
he's logged in. For a small and medium business,
you know, they are already used to using their
e-mail outsourcer. Ping just become, you know,
one more box in the picture that handles a
lot of the complexity for them, and usually
it's just a bunch of check boxes to get set
up. So, we have a couple of different audiences
here. So, some very specific feedback, but,
first, those of you who deal with small and
medium businesses, then we are going to talk
about those of you running software-as-a-service
opportunities and then those of you who are
geeks like me. So, first, you know, small
and medium businesses, like I said before,
"Don't try to run your own login system, you
know, under someone's desk that's going to
die when your executive is traveling. You're
just asking to get yelled at." You know, either
just don't, either just require your employees
to log in to all these applications independently--which
is annoying but not the end of the world,
you know--or look at one of these service
space offering that can provide this in a
more highly reliable way. And another thing
to keep an eye on is, you know, this type
of glue that's happening, you know, it's--I
was just showing you the previous diagram--this
is evolving quickly. These service providers
are offering a lot of other options, integration
with these different protocols, integration
with some stronger authentication mechanism.
If that's really important you, that will--it
has its own usability challenges. And, lastly,
a lot of enterprises are really pushing vendors
like Ping, like Google to make better standards
for how to provision new users across a bunch
of apps or use group membership across all
of them. These are things where standards
are evolving. If you got a lot of time and
want to monitor them, great. If not, you know,
let one of these experts deal with it for
you. So, that's some guidance if you're a
small and medium business. Well, some of you
in the room run software-as-a-service offerings,
so, whether it's for targeted small businesses,
medium businesses, large businesses, it doesn't
really matter, you're almost certainly going
to get pressure from your enterprise customers
to support this type of federated login. Your
security guys, you know, hate it when they
have to take their employee passwords and
send it to a bunch of different vendors. Historically,
most of this pressure came from larger enterprises
who could run these system. But we've--what
we've seen over the last year is that there's
a lot of medium size and even smaller businesses,
are deploying these service based and, their
being providers, they're now putting pressure
on their SaaS when they're saying, you know,
"Hey, I've finally got one of these things.
I want to use it. You know, I don't want my
employees have to log in yet again." So, if
you as a SaaS vendor start feeling this pressure,
you have three choices. One is, well, these
are standards, you can read them, you can
roll your own, and I can pretty much guarantee
you, you're going to make a security mistake
'cause even, you know, experts like Google
and Microsoft and Yahoo and Ping do. And,
you know, this is, you know, hardcoded stuff
to get all the crypto right, so, a more traditional
option is just to purchase one of these software
packages from a vendor in the space. There
are plenty, CAI, IBM, Oracle, Ping as well.
And then one of the more recent trends is--we're
just talking about the fact that a small business
can subscribe to a service that runs on identifier
when the reverse is true. Some companies like
JanRain who offers a service they call "Rpx,"
as well as Ping are going to SaaS vendors
and saying, "Hey, you don't want to run all
this complicated software in your site? Fine.
We'll run it for you as a service on the internet
and we'll just need a small sort of last mile
connection from the relying party they run
on behalf of your company to your company's
website." So, the last audience--and I'm hoping
that there's some of you in this room or actually
do I--oh, okay--one more annoying thing for
those of you who are software-as-a-service
vendors. If you want to run off and do these
today, two warnings that we've learned from
talking with other SaaS vendors who've done
this. The first is to take a look at whether
you offer any desktop software that integrates
with your applications. If you do, you're
probably going to be really annoyed when you
realized that you've hardcoded it to ask users
for their e-mail address and password. Google
has done this, Salesforce has done this. But
then, you know, Facebook fortunately avoided
it, but most of us made this mistake that
our desktop absolutely just hardcoded to ask
for e-mail address and password. If you this
federated login thing, all of a sudden you
don't have passwords for some of your users,
so, you're in trouble. I'm not going to spend
a lot of time on this. If you want to see
about most--best practices for solving that,
there's a technology called "OAuth" that does
it. Down at the bottom there's sort of a web
link. You can search for "goog oauth" and
there's some more detail there. Just look
for the information about desktop apps. The
other challenge for software-as-a-service
providers is they'll have to decide what their
login box looks like. Most of them, if they
have a login box, it's the traditional one--ask
for e-mail address and ask for password. And
if all of a sudden some of your users don't
have a password, you've to decide what should
it look like instead, different options, depending
of what type of vendor you are. One of the
more common ones is just to take away that
password field, ask the user for their e-mail
address and then, you know, look it up and
decide, "Oh, is this someone where I have
a password for them or this someone where
I'm using one of these federated login technologies?"
But, you know, the last thing I wanted to
mention, I like to say--oh, did you--if you
have a question, do you want to come up or...?
Or I can repeat it.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> SACHS: The slides actually, if you do this
search for "goog oauth" right now and go to
the first website link to the search for Google
I/O, the slides are already there. And the
video of this is supposed to be up I think
June 1st, if I remember correctly. Right,
so, like I said, this is a pretty technical
audience. There's some unsolved challenges
left here. A lot of great work is being done
not just by, you know, big companies, Microsoft,
Yahoo, Google, AOL, et cetera, but some really
innovative stuff are coming from, you know,
smaller companies, in particular, ones who
are just willing to, you know, just throw
out past assumptions and try something new.
So, if you want to get involved in this space,
they are couple of standards of steps here:
OpenID, OAuth, SAML. The OAuth mailing list,
you can monitor them, see what's going on
in the space. And there's some, you know,
challenges that we're dealing with. By far,
the number one is about usability. I have
to admit this is an area that's very interesting
for us in the security community. We normally
hide in the corners and, you know, try to
kill the bad demons. Now, we're actually spending
a very large portion of our time learning
from usability experts about how to make this
security technology helpful as opposed to
annoying. We're very good at making it annoying.
That we know don't want to do. And, like I
say, you know, a couple other things, you
know, easier set up for administrators, improving
the security whenever possible, and then the
provisioning and group membership stuff that
I talked about. So, you know, that's the first
section. Like to say, good vendors in the
space, take a look at them. You know, if you're
a SaaS vendor, realize you're probably going
to get some pressure to become a relying party
over the next year. Hopefully, this has some
good pointers. Let me dive into now the next
section topic, a little bit more complicated,
and we're going to spend about two-thirds
of the time here. So, I mentioned that I have
two jobs, the security job and product manager
with our CIO. So, I spend a lot of time with
industry CIOs, government CIOs, and one of
the things that's been really fascinating
with spending time with them is these guys
are really looking at cloud computing technology
as a way to reducing their operating cost.
You know, they want to use things like Azure
or Amazon, Salesforce, Google App Engine,
et cetera. And they're interested in not just
for services like e-mail and CRM, but for
these "platform as a service" offerings where
they can run entire apps on Amazon web services
or in Google App Engine. However, as soon
as they start playing with these, the common
refrain I hear from the CIOs is, "Okay, you
know, if I have app A running on, you know,
one cloud computing vendor and app B running
behind my firewall or another cloud computing
vendor, how are those two going to authenticate
to each other?" So, you know, forget about
end-users. And so here are some very specific
used cases that I'm going to walk through
today that are probably the most common--they
are the most common ones that I've been asked.
So, the first is, you know, a more simple
one: "Great," you know, "I'm just trying to
deal with cross platform connectivity. I build
my front end as a window server. I got backend
running on Linux and I want that, you know,
Windows server to make, you know, application
calls, RPCs to the backend. Well, how does
the backend know the requests are actually
coming from that Windows server and not some
other rogue server in their environment?"
Multiple ways to deal with this. We are going
to talk about one that can also help with
scenarios two and three, which is the next
common scenario. There are a lot of companies
that have said, "Oh, well, there's stuff I
can do at Amazon web services. What they're
offering really meets my needs, and then there
is other functionality that I can more easily
do at App Engine. But how do I combine the
two? How do I have my administrative console,
an App Engine making, you know, function request
to my application running on Amazon to tell
it to say, 'Restart,' or create more instances
of itself?" These are powerful operations.
You want to make sure that the app running
on Amazon wants to make sure it's getting
these requests from the proper source. And
then, you know, the most complicated one,
and especially for enterprises that almost
guarantee that some of their data is going
to be behind the firewall, they're got to
have some software running on premise. So,
how do you integrate or mash up an application
running on the cloud and an application running
on premise behind the firewall? So, we're
going to talk about each of these three used
cases in turn. And, in particular, we're going
to talk about one technology standard called
OAuth that can help in a lot of these areas.
I'm not going to tell you OAuth is exactly
what you should use in all of these cases,
in particular, the first example of Window
server targeting a Linux server--a bunch of
different options to do that. However, if
those two applications are separated and can
only communicate through a firewall with an
issue to be proxy, which is, you know, a common
thing, like Google App Engine Apps can only
make outbound calls, you know, via HTTP and
a lot of enterprises only allowing inbound
requests through HTTP. Well, if you got that
limitation, a lot of web developers, even
before they get to your part, make a decision
to use a REST-style APIs. And if you're not
familiar with that, I want to give an example.
But these are APIs that are designed to look
like request to load a webpage, so they flow
through standard HTTP proxies, firewalls,
et cetera. Of the--all the advantages of OAuth,
though, the biggest one it has is right now
it's really simple. It's only a couple of
pages spec and, in fact, in the enterprise
used cases, you can usually ignore all but
the first page of the spec. So, that simplicity
really attracts an audience because, in general,
in the security space, the more complex something
is, the more likely you are to get it wrong.
And then, did I see, at least, probably a
need here, so I'm going to--one of the other
things I'm going to note is--well, I have
some time at the end to answer some questions.
We're actually running a helpdesk that is
on this floor. Okay, there's a helpdesk right
on this floor. Brian can stand up now and
everyone can look at him. Brian is one of
our OAuth experts at Google. And we have another
one there as well who you can dive down deeper
and some of the stuff if you're interested
afterwards. Okay, so, we can talk about some
very specific examples. The top thing right
there is--ignoring all the security stuff--what
does a REST API call look like? I'm guessing
90 percent of you all do, but just in case,
it's an RPC, Remote Procedure Call, that looks
like the type of thing you would type into
your web browser's URL. So, the top request
is actually a request to change Sara's salary
to $90,000. You know, and in this case, it's
running at this, you know, salary endpoint
on acme.com. And if they chose to, they could
put this up as a web server that anyone could
type that URL in their browser and change
Sara's salary. Now, they probably want to
add some security to that, I hope. So, let's
talk about some ways they can do that. In
particular, the example I want to focus on,
though, is if they have exposed this type
of REST API interface and they expect a front-end
application to make calls to it, so it's not
two-tier user having the endpoint directly.
It's user having some front-end app, and the
front-end app then wants to change Sara's
salary. How is the front-end app going to
make that request and, you know, verify where
it came from? So, what OAuth does, the very
simple version is it says, "You know what,
take that URL that was created for the API
call and just add two things to it. One is
the user URL parameter, which has the claimed
name of the calling application, and you get
to decide what this is." Best practices do
something that looks like a domain name, but
to be honest, it can be anything, any string
that's unique. And then the trickier part
is this last parameter--this OAuth signature
parameter--and what this is designed to do
is to prove that the request actually came
from a specific source. And so this is where
the hard part happens. And so I'm going to
have to give you guys a little bit of the
hard part here, the crypto part, and then
I'm going to talk about, hopefully, over time
how you can stop thinking about those things
because, like I say, the end-goal, to make
securities simple or possible. However, if
this is something that you're really interested
in, you want to jump off and start using this
OAuth-type style, it is an open standard.
There are good open source libraries, you
know, for it that you can take a look at on
oauth.net. So, crypto 101, or called maybe,
you know, crypto 50--it's really a short version,
if you start playing with this stuff, you
will find that the calling application and
the receiving application are going to have
to agree on some secure way to communicate
with each other. The first choice that usually
I have to make is between two of the more
common crypto algorithms. You'll hear the
words HMAC and symmetric as sort of the simpler
one. It appears to be more common in the enterprise
scenarios. RSA, a little bit more complicated
to set off. If you really want to understand
it, grab some box, it's not immediately obvious.
It does some have security advantages to it.
So, their calling app and the receiving app
have to pick one of these two and once they've
picked it, they then have to either exchange
with each other or share a sort of password,
which in this case, they call it secret, or
in the RSA scenario, they're sort of a pair
of secrets. And each guy knows, roughly speaking,
one of the two. So, let's assume that's done.
Let me go back to one of the first examples
I gave that I get asked about. I see it was
the "how do I have a front-end Windows server
talking to a back-end Linux app, you know,
a cross platform from each other?" The first
two-part, pretty standard, you know, create
an API endpoint on the Linux server, call
that from the Windows server. Nothing particularly
tricky there. The third part, not too hard.
The Window server adds one more URL parameter
with the name of the calling application.
And, by the way, I see a lot people standing
at the back. There are a bunch of seats up
front, if you'll all want to come up. It's
where, you know, four and five start to get
a little bit trickier. You know, step four
is where, okay, these two people, the administrator,
it's the Linux, and Windows server, do have
to talk with each other, agree on the crypto
mechanism to use, exchange one of these secrets
with each other. And once they've done that,
they can openly grab one of these open source
libraries for Windows to sign the request
and for Linux to verify the request. Step
seven, by the way, is an important one that's
sadly left out a lot of times, which is--let's
say that Linux server is willing to accept
request from a couple of different Windows
front-ends, but, you know, with different
privileges. One of the Windows front-ends
is allowed to say change salaries and the
other one is only allowed to read information
out of the system. Also, it's not enough for
the Linux server to just verify the request
as properly signed and then ask to look at,
oh, okay, and who did it come from and what
operation are they allowed to perform, which,
obviously, a lot of cases where that step
gets skipped and people assume just verifying
the signature is enough. So, some of you have
laptops or, you know, phones probably, and,
hopefully, have started Googling OAuth to
learn a little bit more about it. One morning,
if you do, I mentioned before, this is a technology
that started in the consumer space and now
has evolved into the enterprise space. If
you start reading about it, you'll see a lot
of references to, you know, consumer brands--Yahoo,
AOL, Google, Flickr, a bunch of others--who
created this. One nice thing to know is they
created this not from scratch, they all had
sort of proprietary variants over ahead of
time. They tried to merge their best practices,
come up with a common standard and the security
guides on all these companies keep on banging
on it and looking for ways to improve it so
you got to leverage all that experience. However,
if you read about the OAuth standard, you'll
see a lot of description of flows where an
end-user has to approved application A and
application B talking to each other about
that user. Consumer scenarios, that makes
sense. You want user consent. In the enterprise
scenarios or, you know, web-app to web-app
by itself, usually don't need this. It's overly
complicated. So, if you read about OAuth and
see anything about tokens, just, like, skip
to the next section. If you see the word token,
just skip to the next section. If you do that,
you end up throwing out about 2/3 of the OAuth
spec and you're left with something that's
pretty simple. Pretty simple, but we always
want to try to make it simpler. Like I say,
you get to the point where security is just
this invisible glue down at the bottom. And
so let me talk about another standard. We've
talked about OpenID in the sample at the beginning.
We just talk about OAuth. I'm going to throw
in one more for you, which is OpenSocial.
So, another consumer-developed standard, however,
one of the things that the OpenSocial community
realizes, you know what, in the cloud computing
environment, a lot of times the applications
are run in a container, and the container
knows the identity of the application and
can provide some services to it to help with
things like identity management. Google and,
you know, app engines, Salesforce, for example,
provide a lot of features in their containers,
you know, so do the OpenSocial containers.
And what they realize is, hey, the container
can provide a function call to the app to
handle all this OAuth signature stuff on the
application's behalf. So if the app wants
to make this REST call to change Sara's salary,
it just goes to the container, looks up the
container's specific function to proxy one
of these URLs and says, "Hey, container, I
want to call this URL and, please, can you
handle all the signature stuff for me?" And
this is, like I say, already live and open
search containers, and what the community
right now is trying to do in the OAuth community
is standardize this working for other containers,
whether it's other Google containers, Salesforce,
as well as Yahoo, et cetera. So, you know,
let's assume that you do take this type of
approach and, you know, and your container
can sign the request. Well, the recipient
is going to get something that looks like,
you know, the request at the top. And one
of the things that, hopefully, you'll notice
from here is there are now three special parameters
out instead of two. You know, before there
was the signature and there was this consumer
key. Now, the OpenSocial guys came with this
idea, "Well, let's you know, throw in, you
know, a claim as to the source of the calling
application." You know, Microsoft loves to
talk about claims based [INDISTINCT] management.
In this case, you know, the container, you
know, appspot.com, is making the claim that
it is sign your request on behalf of a particular
app like hrtool.appspot.com. So, you know,
to do this, it takes all of the signing work
off the application. And there's another advantage
to it, which is that the containers can and,
certainly do in the OpenSocial, they can document
how they're going to do the signing, how they're
going to do the crypto. They'll give, you
know, very good sample code as to how to verify
these requests. So, it really offloads a lot
of the complexity for the developer, especially
developer creating the front-end application.
So, let me give an example now of, you know,
how this could work, you know, with--once
we've finalized standards for how a container
like App Engine can do this request. So, if
you want to play with it, just look at how
OpenSocial containers do it, you know, with
95 percent finalized stuff. So, the first
thing is, okay, the Amazon app, the one, you
know, not running in the container, still
needs to expose an API endpoint and the calling
apps still needs to make a request, you know,
with one of these REST API formats that looks
like URL. Now, though, the only thing that's
left is, you know, nothing more for the calling
app to do. The Amazon app just needs to look
at the documentation of the container, find
out what format it used, how it's handling
digital signatures, hopefully even grab some
sample code, verify the request came from
this app, and, like I mentioned before, also
check that application has the ability to
perform this operation. Even more dangerous,
number four, and so I want to [INDISTINCT]
calling apps again, if the code for verifying
request from a container is consistent, that
means in this case that the Amazon server
could--will be able to verify a sign request
from any application running on that container.
So, if all you do is verify the request came
from that container and then allow it to say
"change Sara's salary," you're in trouble.
You need to take the extra step of looking
at that previous parameter, this app URL and
making sure that it is the trusted source
for making the request. So, if you want to
play with this, now, like say, you can do
this today. You don't have to wait for us
to, you know, finalized the mechanism for
the container to do the signing. Do the search
for OAuth Google App Engine, there are software,
for example, out there that do this today,
not to--or like I say, a bunch of enterprises
are already using them. Again, assuming you're
comfortable with that, you know, if you want,
you know, wait a little bit longer or start
out with just a gadget functionality, which
already does the signing. As soon as the industry
standard community signs off on it, this is
sort of the nice thing, all right, you don't
want individual companies deciding the final
standards on this 'cause then you'd just have
to do with [INDISTINCT]. So, we want to make
sure that, you know, and a bunch of us have
agreed, "Okay, we're all going to do it the
same way." He's asking what it was about.
I'm going to--and I was saying when the community
as a whole has, you know, agreed with standards
on it. Google is not trying to this on their
own. Okay, let's make it a little bit more
complicated. We've talked about, you know,
Window server having Linux server. We talked
about App Engine app, talking to Amazon. Well,
let's say you're trying to break your way
through a firewall. You have an application
running on, you know, App Engine, or to be
honest, on Salesforce, on AdSure, et cetera,
and Amazon and you want to connect to, say,
you know, some APIs exposed with your ERP
system. Well, now it gets a little bit more
complicated. There are three things you need
to do. The first is you're going to have to
find some way to tunnel through that enterprise
firewall to the ERP system. Different softwares--I'm
sorry, different cloud computing vendors offer
different ways to do this. Google has an offer
called the Secure Data Connector that's designed
to help with this. There are sessions about
that later today. Other cloud computing vendors,
you know, suggests using more standard point
to point VPN tunnels. You know, the standards
there are pretty well established. So, that's,
you know, the first thing you need to do.
The second thing you need to do is, you know,
this OAuth-style interaction to verify the
source of the request. However, then there's
one last thing, which is in most enterprises
situations, if you don't care just about what
front-end app is making the request, you care
about what user is logged into that front-end
request. So, you know, who is it that wants
to change Sara's salary tends to be an important
question when dealing with like an ERP application.
And this is again the case where the OpenSocial
community saw the same problem and, you know,
came up with a way to address it that a lot
of enterprises are adopting, which is they
said, "Okay, well, we just need to pass another
claim as to the identity of the user." And
so, the application, you know, can pass along
that claim. And it's really up to the back-end
to decide does it trust it. You know, maybe
some applications it trusts to, you know,
identify or subset abusers. You know, are
they applications to trust to identify a whole
set? But, in any case, you know, the calling
application is just going to pass along another
URL parameter with the claimed name of the
user who's logged in. You could make this
URL parameter named anything you want. However,
there's a lot of value to being, you know,
having standards about this, to answer your
earlier questions. You know, a little bit
of variance can be annoying. In the OpenSocial
community, they have chosen the parameter
OpenSocial viewer e-mail as a common one in
this scenario. And let me give you an example
of why it might be helpful to follow that
standard. I'm going to, you know, reverse
this now. In the previous example, it's, okay,
you know, an app engine trying to make a call
back through the enterprise. What if it's
the reverse? What if an enterprise is using
some software as service vendor, Salesforce
or Google Apps, for example, and it wants
to make a call into that SaaS vendor? So a
common example Google gets is we host a lot
of companies, e-mail and calendar offerings.
And we actually offer a feature right now,
or what administrator can do is go to Google
and say, "You know what, I'd like to turn
on this sort of two-legged OAuth interaction
for my domain. I want one of these OAuth consumer
keys and secrets." And once they have that
in their hands, they can actually write an
application themselves, run it wherever they
want, and it can make this two-legged OAuth
calls back to Google, and Google will say,
"Oh, I just got a request to, in this case,
you know, return the, you know, calendar for
Tom in a certain domain." Well, one of the
things to note is if the consumer key and
consumer secret, if all it does is identify
the domain, and the domain wants a particular
users data, it's going to have to tell us
what user's data it wants. So, we, as Google,
have to decide what URL parameter we require,
you know, for this information we passed in.
To be honest, we use a couple a different
ones because, you know, the community is still
trying to finalize some of the standards on
this, though it's really just standards of
picking, you know, names to make things as
simple as possible. So, OpenSocial viewer
e-mail, like I say, is an example of such
a name. This is another topic all in itself.
If you are a company who has outsourced Google,
if you are interested in learning more about
how to build your own apps to access these
APIs, there's another session--Building Enterprise
Applications in the Cloud--that's worth going
to. Common example of using this is maybe
you want to upload a bunch of data about your
users into the system 'cause you're migrating
or you want to scan the data to a SaaS vendor
for legal complaint searches, that type of
thing. Again, though, I want to get back to
my theme of how simple can we make this. So,
you know, we talked about before that the
OpenSocial community have this idea of, hey,
allow the container to sign the request on
behalf of the app. In the OpenSocial, what
they actually do is the container in many
cases knows not only the identity of the application,
it also knows the identity of the user who's
currently logged in to that application. And
so what the container will do when you add
this signed parameter is it will actually
add that viewer's e-mail to the assertion.
It does this by default. In fact, I'm not
even sure how you'd turn it off. So, now the,
you know, if the container is passing to the
claim that Tom is logged in and the claim
that it's this particular application that's
making the request and just to sort of, you
know, steal some, you know, Microsoft's terminology,
these, you know, claims are all a matter of
trust. Does the back-end application trust
these claims? And one of the things it has
to decide is does it trust the calling application
to get the crypto right, to do all that digital
signatures right? And in many cases, you know,
you're nervous about, you know, your average
software engineer doing this, right? However,
if the container is run by, you know, an Amazon
or Saleforce, Google, Yahoo, you can be pretty
sure that they've gotten this right as we
know how and they will evolve it over time
if need be. So in many cases, these claims
are even more trustworthy than if the application
sent them. And to give--an even more specific
example is, you know, right now the container
is asserting that Tom has logged in. Well,
that's an interesting piece of information
that not only is the action being performed
on behalf of Tom, but he's currently logged
in to that application. That's not an easy
claim for a standard loan application to make
and for something else to trust. So, you know,
the app can claim that Tom's logged in, but
for the container to make that claim in many
cases, it's more trustworthy. Again, you know,
claims and trust, you know, it's really a
matter for you to make, you know, your decisions,
but this one of the advantages of containers.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> SACHS: So, we're just asking, you know,
more generally, you know, how does the container
keep track of, you know, [INDISTINCT] other
mechanisms to identify who Tom is? There are
a lot of various containers, the way that
gadgets do authentication of users is actually
pretty complex because you have multiple individual
applications running on the page on the user's
browser, so, there, you know, you have to
deal with complication. It's not just code
running on the server side, so, significant
complexly there. For things like saleforce.com,
App Engine, et cetera, if you look at them,
they already provide the applications a way
for the application running on those platforms
to tell who has logged in. And so the same
way they do that, they're just adding that
to these assertion information. So, it tends
to be proprietary to that, you know, platform
as opposed to standard and that--in this case,
that's fine. But our key goal is to be--have
a standard for how we assert that information.
Does that a help? We can drill down to it
more after this one. Okay, so, we spent a
lot of time talking about how to make it easier
to sign these outbound requests and, you know,
things the industry is doing to, hopefully,
over time, make this even simpler. However,
there's still the reverse. The calling application
still has to verify the signatures. Fortunately,
this is much simpler. I mentioned before that,
you know, if the signature is coming from
a container, a lot of these containers have
really good docs on how to do a really good
sample code, however, there still is a chance
for mistake. So, one of the things that we're
trying to figure out is how could we probably
do sort of the reverse of the signing feature
and instead just verify that one of these
request came in. So, you know, for example,
a container, you know, an app entered the
Salesforce, Amazon could provide a service
to verify these request, and you know, if
you want to make a call into it, then you
would go to Google or Yahoo and say, okay,
how do I get one of these consumer keys, consumer
secrets, so I can make an inbound sign request.
If you want to play with this today, like
I said, there's already a software available
to do this for the app engine [INDISTINCT]
for a couple of examples. But in this software,
you have to bring it in, if it gets updated
you have to, you know, keep track of that.
So, that's what we want to make simpler over
time. So, we're actually getting near the
end, so you'd start thinking about your questions.
We need to take this up, two more levels,
you know, to make a key point at the end.
Let's talk about how simple, you know, we're
trying to make this, which is--let's use the
example of two GAE applications. What if you
decide you want to write the front-end of
your application on the Python version of
Google App Engine and you want to write the
back-end in, say, the Java version of, you
know, Google App Engine, but you need a way
for the two to securely communicate with each
other and your backend wants to make sure
the requests really are in fact coming from
that font-end and out? This is possible today,
plenty of developers have already done it,
and many of them use these OAuth software
mechanisms to do it. However, our goal is
to get to the point where that first application
just makes a sign request fall into this OpenSocial-style
standard and the receiving system gets the
URL listed under GAE app 2. You know, a request
to change Sara's salary where it sees it comes
from Tom, sees the calling GAE application
and all it does now is verify the signature
is accurate first. Second thing, like I say,
very, very important, don't forget this, make
sure that the app who made the request is
actually allowed to perform the operation.
Verifying the signature by itself is not sufficient.
And now I can look at the value of Tom and
Sara and see, "Hey, is Tom allowed to change
Sara's salary? Is he her boss or, you know,
an HR Manager?" So, you know, physical, you
know, replace this software for URL verify
and the software for URL fetch, you know,
with services that can do this in our app
so that the applications just need to perform
this access control checks. That's between
two GAE apps though. The reason for trying
to do this as a standard is, like I say, you
can already do that, that's not the most interesting
thing in the world. What the OAuth community
and what other companies are trying to do
is how do you do these mashups across cloud
computing platform? How do you have an app
on Azure to make a call to an app on Amazon
or an app on Salesforce make a call to Google
App Engine and, you know, for the containers
to establish standards on how to do all these
crypto to each other so that you don't even
think about it? You just say, "I want to make
a request. Here is the URL at that point I'm
trying to hit. I want it signed". If you are
the receiving system, you get the request.
You say I want to verify it, "Oh great, it
came from another container that interrupts
with the container I'm hosting." You know,
this is where the community is trying to get,
it's to use OAuth as a way to do these types
of screen mashups across different cloud computing
platforms. And so, like I say, for those of
you who want to do stuff like this today,
the software does exist, plenty of enterprises
use it for some pretty high value transactions.
Look at some of the websites or web searchers
have reference to get more detail. But, in
particular, I'm hoping this is a very tight,
highly sophisticated audience, we just like
in the federated login space, we are looking
for more people to help us, you know, flush
out all of these stands. We have great people
from all these different companies, Microsoft,
Amazons, Salesforce and Google. It represents
a good mix up in this space, but we'd like
to hear more. In particular, many of us are
a little bit more focused on the consumers'
space. We need a bit more enterprise prospective.
To be honest, sometimes we need to be banged
up the side of the head to remember that the
enterprise segment is a little bit different.
And so, if you want to get involved in this,
OAuth mail list is a public one. There are
other great industry conferences like the
Internet Identity Workshop that just happened
last week where there was a lot of good discussions
to finalize this stuff in the next few weeks,
and, so, I'd hope you would come to that in
the future. So, you know, I'm going to stay
around for questions for people who want to
go up the mics. I'll also be around after,
so if people want to catch me in the hall,
if you want to learn even more about OAuth
while you're here at the conference, stop
by the OAuth helpdesk. And if you want to
get more details about pretty much anything
I'd talked about, let's say, do a Google search
for OAuth Goog, the first website there has
a ton of information about all of the things
we talked about today. And what you'll see
is it's not just information from Google.
There's a great usability research links from
Yahoo, Facebook, Plaxo, et cetera. A lot of
different people play in this space and, like
I say, we're looking for other people to play
in the space to help us at OAuth. Thank you
very much for y'all's time. And like I say,
if people just want to go up to the mic and
ask questions, I'll do my best to answer as
much as can now and stay after for people
who want more detailed information.
>> A lot of us have Legacy applications that
have their own layering of authentication,
authorization, and somehow we are trying to
connect with cloud deployed. And so we're
looking both for authentication as well as
authorization, not just authentication alone
with--minding that the ID is different as
well as the password maybe different in different
Legacy systems.
>> SACHS: Right. And, so, there are a couple
of different piece app, one of things he's
asking is, "Hey, what if we have a Legacy
system, what is it designed to do with all
these OAuth and REST API from the beginning?
What if it was designed to deal with more
like a WS-Trust or something else?" This is
where, you know, again, community stuff is
really helpful. A lot of the companies that
have been more in the enterprise space, you
know, Microsoft, IBM, CA, et cetera, are coming
and saying exactly it's, you know, hey, there
is this API endpoint in the enterprise. All
it knows and how to do is to get a blob in
this HTTP header and then to either statically
validate it in a certain way or send it over
to this internal token server to verify it.
So, one of the things that we're working to
try to standardize OAuth is how can a calling
application make a request to the enterprise
and go there like a central sort of enterprise
and go to [INDISTINCT] enterprise and say,
"Hey, I want to talk to your ERP application.
Can you be a little bit more sophisticated,
can you talk OAuth, so I can prove who I am
and give me back a token that maybe only lasts
for five minutes, that I can then send to
a more Legacy application that, you know,
only it deals with a token and a proprietary
format?" So, how do you use OAuth as a way
to bootstrap, grabbing one of this piece of
information? So that, you know, that's part
of it. Another part is, okay, a lot of those
applications are looking for assertions in
that blob as to say, you know, the membership
of that group, like, you know, is he in the
auditors, you know, team for example. And,
again, these central identity services, token
service, whatever you want to call it, they
can use OAuth as a way to bootstrap, you know,
get information about, say, you know, Tom
in my example or the application URL, and
then swap it with, say, this proprietary blob
that still has Tom's name and maybe even [INDISTINCT]
company and looked up and said, "Is Tom an
HR person?" and then stick that in the blob
that, you know, it sent along. And so Ping,
IBM, CA, et cetera, they already provide these
types of token servers that run in an enterprise
and deal with things WS-Trust, WS-Fed, SAML,
et cetera, and OAuth is just another, you
know, combination in the alphabets soup mix
that they're looking to see can they act as
a bridge, you know, to these central applications,
just as in one of your early examples I showed,
how PingConnect can be sort of a broker bridge
to a lot of federated login offenders. These
guys are trying to write software to be that
sort of last half-mile bridge. And, hopefully,
that's helpful. We can talk more if you want
to... Yeah?
>> So, there's--there has been a lot of focus.
I use Amazon Interview quite a bit and now
I'm kind of trying to link a couple of things
between Amazon and the Google App Engine,
the security, there's been a lot of focus
to use GET as opposed to POST, and a lot of
times if we have data that we're actually
trying to send over and I understand the purpose
of using, you know, the signatures, if you're
adding--I mean you're limiting the size of
this URL and we're limited by that and, ultimately,
I mean, we have to do something about this.
And if somebody--and also if somebody wants
to just mess with the system for the sake
of messing with it and just choose 200 lines
with their names for the username...
>> SACHS: Yup.
>> ...this thing breaks.
>> SACHS: Right.
>> So, what's your solution to that?
>> SACHS: So, you might want to catch Bryan
and he'll help us afterwards for more detail.
There is a mix for, you know, body signing
as opposed to just signing the head. We're
not seeing it getting used as much as we would
have anticipated. Like, we felt we were going
to run into that URL problem, like, six, nine
months ago. We proposed some standards for
how to deal with it. I'm not sure if they've
been finalized. Like, I think they're, like,
they're posted, some people used them. But
they haven't just been used enough for people
to say it absolutely works, you know. We have
data that that function works, enough individuals,
but we'd like to see heavier user Java to
sort of, you know, formally ratify, yes, this
is the correct way to do it. The other challenge
that we have, again, for those who want to
get more deeper in the crypto aspect is creating
these signatures is complicated. A lot of
people find that signing something that's
in a URL format has a lot of complexity to
it. Signing just a blob that's, you know,
in the body, is in many case actually easier.
So not only does it avoid the length problems,
but in many case it's just easier. So, I think
search for OAuth body signing, Bryan is that...
Yeah, so, if you do a Google search for all
that body signing, you'll see a spec for how
people are doing for some of that today.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> SACHS: So, for those of you here, if you--Bryan
is saying, if you got a lot of data, you have
to use POST. You really don't have another
option for you. Cool. Great. Anyone else who
want to volunteer and stand up for the mic?
If not, like I say, I'm going to hang around
and answer questions individually.
>> I also have a question in regards to the
container authenticating to multiple applications
and potentially having a cookie for each application.
How does the web browser secure the--or attempt
to secure those cookies so they cannot be
stolen by some other application running inside
the web browser so that they're in a secured
container that can only be accessed by one
of the member applications within that container?
>> SACHS: All right. The dumb version is use
one sub-domain for app if you're able to do
that, which they, you know, like Google App
Engine can. If, however, your apps ran a single
domain like they do with gadgets, this becomes
a much more with complex story. In fact, like
it's so complex that that's why OpenSocial
had to be a standard. So, it could be pushed
out there and other people could look at the
code and see that, "Oh, yes, they did find
a way to do that." It's very tricky. It took
a while to get it right, probably nine months,
and most of it was Bryan [INDISTINCT] over
there, by the way, if you're asking for more
details. But, like I say, people weren't sure
was it even going to be possible, so we had
to make, you know, open source [INDISTINCT]
so people could review and say, "Oh, yeah,
actually, you know, those mechanisms do work."
And, usually, it involves still running each
gadget and its own sub-domain actually with
a--unique to that sub-domain token that identifies
the user to the user's web--you know, to the
end-user, it looks like they're all running
within one URL, one domain, but, you know,
there are hidden iFrames to independent sub-domains.
Okay? Sure.
>> And my next question was, I don't know
if you have mentioned the secure mashups of
framework...
>> SACHS: Right.
>> ...and the availability of those secured
channels between two, for instance, two widgets
or two gadgets running within your browser
where they can encrypt the communication,
they can, if you will, authenticate each other
and exchange data within the browser itself.
>> SACHS: Yeah, so if you're--so, put yourself
around, if you do have a multiple gadgets,
say, running on a page and they want to communicate
with each other, they can communicate through
the server side channel. It tends to be slow,
you know, a lot of latency. There are a lot
of tricks, and then the various web browsers,
how they can communicate within the page,
however, the variance across the different
web browsers is pretty high. So, actually
there is, I think it's called IFPC, is an
open source set of code within OpenSocial
that actually has, like, eight different ways
of doing this and auto detects, you know,
what browser is used and what, you know, browser,
you know, version is used and then it tries
to use the fastest one. So, some of that code
is actually available and you can grab it
if you want to use it.
>> Thank you.
>> SACHS: Sure.
>> Yeah, hi. I have a question. I really like
REST APIs, et cetera, really awesome. But
is there any thoughts within OAuth to support
other RPC protocols like XML-RPC or JSON-RPC
which steal around over HTTP?
>> SACHS: Sure. So, there actually are a lot
of enterprises who use it for basically SOAP
request. What they end up doing, like SOAP,
you know, short version is SOAP generally
suggests putting the identity of the calling
app and even the calling user within the payload
of the application. And what we're seeing
a lot of enterprise doing is saying, "You
know what, just take those two parameters
and pass them in the URL and use OAuth to
sign them and have the SOAP endpoint get everything
it needs other than those two parameters from
the requests." So, we see that one. The other
variant we see slightly more complicated is
that if the enterprise does have one of these
on-site sort of tokens server things that
were mentioned before, you--you're, you know,
calling application can make your call to
that one that's just OAuth and get back a
blob and then stick that blob in the SOAP
parameter that it makes, you know, to a final
Legacy endpoint. So, those are two different
models that we're seeing now. It's not obvious
if one is better than the other or if it really
just depends on the used case.
>> One issue that you didn't really deal with,
and I don't know if this the appropriate form,
but really handling the different secrets
and keys and so forth because...
>> SACHS: Yes, "crypto high G" as we call
it. That's probably the number one reason
we'd like to change this from being a software-based
solution to a service-based offering. Like
I say, you know, if the application is running
on two different containers and, you know,
Google on one side and Yahoo on the other
side are doing all the crypto underneath,
I'm going to trust them to get the crypto
right to rotate the secrets frequently, you
know, use RSA to bootstrap each track and
all these, you know, tricky things. So, yes,
right now, it is very common for, sadly, enterprise
at some point and stuff, "not have a good
crypto hygiene." For those of you who are,
you know, too involved in this, the most common
example is an administrator, an access to
one of these powerful secrets and he leaves
the company or he's fired and you don't change
it and he still has it and he can make, you
know, request and impersonate one of your
applications. So, getting the crypto hygiene
is good. While containers are trying to getting
into this, like I said, PingConnect is offerings
some early versions of an OAuth platform to
also deal with the stuff, however, the standards
for that type of crypto hygiene doing it automatically
are still only in just propose stages. We
haven't seen solid use of them yet to decide
what's the best approach. Okay. I think we're
at a good stopping point. So I appreciate
all of you who all came by and didn't run
off to get your new toys. Thanks.